Leute zockt mehr computerspiele das ist das resümee unseres heutigen videos immer mal wieder heißt es ja dass
Computerspiele dumm machen aber jetzt gibt es den endgültigen gegenbeweis und zwar direkt aus der wissenschaft ein
experiment hat nämlich gezeigt dass man durch regelmäßiges computerspielen vorteile beim lernen hat und das zeigt sich auch
Im gehirn jedes experiment genau ablief und warum diese ergebnisse auch für die ältere generation
Durchaus spannend sein könnten jetzt sind links und science und fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja schon früher man haben ja untersuchungen gezeigt
computerspiele können positive effekte haben die reaktionszeit kann durch regelmäßiges joggen
verkürzt werden und zudem können gamer durch das spielen ihr
Arbeitsgedächtnis stärken ein forschungsteam aus sind bochum hat uns jetzt einen weiteren grund geliefert weiterhin
regelmäßig zeit mit der spielekonsole zu verbringen die
34 probanden die iris experiment unterteilt sich in zwei gruppen 17 von ihnen hatten angegeben würden sich mehr als 15 stunden
video spiele zu zocken die anderen 17 teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer machten sie das dagegen eher selten
In dem experiment aus bochum hatten die probanden die aufgabe den sogenannten
Wettervorhersage presse zu machen dabei handelt es sich
um einen etablierten test der das lernen von wahrscheinlichkeiten abfahren dabei werden kombinationen
aus drei spielen karten angezeigt wobei sie mit unterschiedlichen wahrscheinlichkeit für regen und sonnenschein
verknüpft sind die probanden kennen die erstmal nicht sie schätzen die wahrscheinlichkeit der symbol
kombinationen ein und bekommen dann die antwort ob ihre einschätzung eben korrekt war oder nicht mit der zeit
Werden sie durch dieses feedback also in die lage versetzt zu verstehen welche kombinationen was bedeuten sie lernen also
Welche karten kombination für welche wettervorhersage stehen am ende des experiments
Füllten alle probanden dann noch einen fahrer bog aus in dem das wissen
Über die spielkarten und ihre bedeutung zusätzlich noch einmal abgefragt wurde und ihr könnt es euch
sicher denken die gamer waren signifikant besser waren die spielkarten korrekt
Mit den wahrscheinlichkeiten zu verknüpfen deutlich besser als die kontrollgruppe
schnitten sie vor allem beispiel kombination mit, hoher unsicherheit ab also wenn die kombination der spielkarten zu
60% sonne und zu 40% regen vorher sagte zum beispiel auch das ergebnis der frage würden überzeugte das forschungsteam von dem guten abschneiden
Der gamer im vergleich zur kontrollgruppe
denn hier wurde deutlich dass diejenigen die häufig zocken die bedeutung der karten besser durchschauen als
Die an und sabrina schenk eine der beteiligten wissenschaftlerinnen sagt dazu unsere studie zeigt dass videospieler besser planen sind situationen
schnell zu erfassen neues wissen zu generieren und wissen zu
Kategorisieren ja und für dieses ergebnis sieht man sie auch gleich eine erklärung mit ihrer ansicht nach
simulieren computerspiele bestimmte hirnregion zocken ist also training für das gehirn das liegt auch eine
Magnetresonanztomographie nadi gemacht wurde. Im rahmen dieses experiments. Im gehirn der gamer war der hippocampus während des lernprozesses
deutlich aktiver als bei der kontrollgruppe
und genau diese hirnregion spielt eine entscheidende rolle beim lernen und für
gedächtnisleistung und dieses ergebnis ist nicht nur für die gamer unter und seine super nachricht auch ältere generationen
Könnten von den positiven effekten des videospiels profitieren denn im hippocampus finden
Im alltag veränderungen statt die leistung des gedächtnisses nimmt ab das könnte wiederum
mit
videospielen
Therapiert werden ja wie immer als ich euch zu diesem thema und zu allen anderen auf dem laufenden wenn er kein video verpassen wollt dann
Dort wer hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Auf die glocke ja hier geht es weiter mit gaming ist gesund das ist nämlich auch noch spannendes video ansonsten bis dann
bleibt